how much did
the fact that you both were using drugs
contribute to the end of your marriage
probably 100
yeah yeah
you said you felt like if you never got
divorced whitney would still be alive
today yes why
because i was i was working on myself
diligently um
i had stopped you know using and um
i feel that um we would have both ended
up the same way um
as far as stopping how long have you
been sober i've been sober
i want to say seven and a half years
one of the hardest parts i think in this
in this documentary to watch was you
going to visit
the graves
and when all my strength is gone
going to visit
whitney's grave and bobby christina's
grave what was that day like
for you
that was a rough one that was really
rough
i don't like grave sites i don't i don't
go to funerals i got through it
we said our goodbyes
and we say him
all the time i mean yeah you know
she still comes she still comes to us
whitney still talks to you oh yeah she
still comes
so
just every now and then you'll hear hell
to the naw
from life with whitney to overcoming a
sex addiction bobby is totally candid in
a e's new biography bobby brown the
two-night event which also follows his
journey to super stardom kicks off may
30th
[Music]
at one point
the money was just coming in so
fast and quick for you you spent a
million dollars in one day yes
well i challenged myself to do it oh you
so that was intentional it was
intentional okay it was intentional so i
went and bought a house i went and
bought a car i went and bought what two
watches three watches i also did not
know you've had two heart attacks yes i
have two stints in my heart um
recently it's never a dull day with
bobby i'll tell you that i want to show
you a clip from your very first
interview that we did with you here at
entertainment tonight i don't like when
people say yeah you're a big star now
your big star wow i i said no i'm not a
big star because i don't feel like a
star i don't i don't let i don't let
people treat me like a star
i don't feel like a star what would you
tell that young man oh take your time
take your time and uh
just relax and your staff yeah
that boston accent was so there that's
real bostonian
bobby's also got a new reality series on
the network bobby brown every little
step premiering may 31st everybody
excited
it's a fun side of bobby we don't see a
lot of featuring his wife alicia and
their three children it's a little
mayhem in the house which is always fun
they keep us on our toes bobby keeps us
laughing and he's the chef in our house
so you'll see a lot of cooking and love
around you know our dinner table and
just really enjoying our lives and
getting through the tough times together
[Music]
you